louis de funès notre trésor national
doit faire l'objet d'une exposition
l'année prochaine à la cinémathèque
française
sauf que ça fait pas l'unanimité il ya
un critique cinématographique c'est pas
le jean christophe ferrari qu'avec un
texte peut-être définitif en dix ans
cette annonce suscite en moi
malaise et inquiétude en gros pour
l'huile ou de funès a rien à faire à la
cinémathèque qui est une institution
parce que il n'a rien inventé de
nouveaux il n'a pas donné corps à un
type de personnage qui n'existait pas
auparavant
et puis il ya une forme de nouvelles
bien pensants selon lui parce que ça
flatte le populo dit il a entre
guillemets quand même de deux d'honorer
louis de funès et aussi les élites qui
cède un hédonisme régressif
alors vous qui est tous les quatre
membres de l'élite est-ce que vous
tombez dans un hédonisme régressif juste
avant ça juste pour le plaisir on se
remet et 30 secondes louis de funès
[Musique]
voit que t'es pas déchaussé encore la
masse que vous avez là puisque vous me
proposez c'est gentiment vous prêter mon
joli bonnet allons d'ailleurs je n'ai ni
permis de conduire ni carte ni assurance
ni comment vous appelez-vous d'étampés
hier comme l'oiseau vous mais bon on a
dream a tous je peux que attester que ça
fait plutôt rire sur le plateau s'est
extrait non parce que la cinémathèque
française je le disais c'est une espèce
de de conservatoire du patrimoine
cinématographique est ce que louis de
funès est à sa place
oui mais en fait je voulais revenir sur
ce que vous disiez vous dit il sans le
lire et qui n'est pas unanimité sur le
fait que huit finesse il ya sa place
en fait je pense qu'il ya quasi
unanimité bon j'ai lu le l'article du
figaro qui maquille qui m'a intéressé 1
mais je crois que ça y est c'est une
réaction à un article juin le transfuge
que je connaissais pas oui voilà qui
articles de ce alors que jean-christophe
faire un bon je vais me permet d'être un
petit peu acide envers le figaro je
pense que le figaro a été très vexé
d'être remis dans quand la bien pensante
pour une fois et alors certes il ya
peut-être une petite intelligentsia
parisienne qui écrit qui pousse des cris
d'orfraie quand on essaie de reconnaître
le groupe populaire mais je pense aussi
que ça peut traduire la la peau une
proportion du figaro à vouloir d'initier
le snobisme des bobos même temps les
reconduisent obscures alors j'ai dit ah
vous envie de défendre notre journal
préféré
bien sûr je trouve qu'il ya d'ailleurs
une espèce de
le pédantisme spécifique à la cinéphilie
qui était assez agaçant espèce de
snobisme pour de miami -les que je
trouve très très énervant parce que
c'est un peu le refuge de dunes oueds
une nouvelle nouvelle intelligentsia qui
aime bien
une prise et la populaire et je moi je
trouve que évidemment je suis une énorme
fan de louis de funès et d'antalis et de
il ya un culte familial autour de lui tu
n'es ce jeu là vous est donc en sait
quelque chose voilà treize ans crée mais
c'est intéressant parce que
effectivement on pouvait se dire la
cinémathèque normalement fait d'être
style plutôt sur des réalisateurs et
c'est vrai que la spécifité démissionner
c'est qu'on connaît plus dans ses films
ses films pour lui que pour les
réalisateurs ou gérard oui personne il y
aurait jamais une rétrospective gérard
oury je pense à la cinémathèque
mais il ya un truc cible de funès parce
que il a créé un personnage qui incarne
une partie de l'histoire de france de la
même manière qu'on ait eu d'artagnan
où bergera je pense qu'il incarne un
type france est une espèce de statique
du bourgeois râleurs pas très très très
antipathique danser dans ses films et
jeux toujours qu'au personnage
antipathique mais qu'ils auront
justement si sympathique et il a fini
par incarner une forme d'essence du
français alors il ya presque la même
unanimité sur ce sujet là que sur le
précédent
parmi nos internautes pour ou contre une
rétrospective louis de funès à la
cinémathèque française pour 86% fable
nous dit c'est un très grand acteur qui
a marqué des générations de français du
mime de la répartie toute une époque
yoann un acteur extraordinaire r34 il
nous a fait rire et c'est déjà beaucoup
nicolas le coc simple vous partagez
d'abord cet avis général et si c'est le
cas j'aurai une autre question pour vous
alors dab évidemment est ce que vous
êtes d'accord est ce que votre à votre
avis louis de funès à la cinémathèque
c'est bien ah oui bien sûr c'est bien et
la fin de l'article de cette revue la
transfuge enfin je sais ce que j'appelle
de la censure progressiste et lui de
financement j'ai grandi avec eux j'ai
appris le français avec avec louis de
funès c'est un symbole ça fait ça fait
la gloire de la france 1 et ça fait
toujours un surtout dans les pays de
l'est que je connais un peu et avec
alain delon belmondo gérard depardieu
c'est quand même inadmissible de dire ça
d'autant plus je regarde un peu ce
qu'organise la cinémathèque française on
l'a vu récemment sergio leone et on a vu
sergio corbucci donc c'est quand même
c'est quand même inadmissible de ne pas
m
les de funès le chaplin français dans le
panthéon des grandes un grand comédien
inimitable quelqu'un d'inimitable comme
vous nous parlez de de l'apprentissage
du français qui est pour vous des plus
fluides
je veux demander quel était qu'elle
était l'accent qu'on perçoit encore dans
votre quelle est l'origine de l'accès de
roumanie où j'ai la chance de voir
quelques films de de funès et et qu'on
me compassé un peu de temps en temps et
c'était s'éteindre c'est un exemple pour
nous et puis qu'est ce que nous a fait
rire et ça fait toujours rire oui ça n'a
pas vieilli non mais oh non mais bien
sûr que non moi gg
je regardais ça quand j'étais jeune avec
ma grand mère je j'ai fait regarder ça à
mes enfants quand elle était plus jeune
et encore ça pourrait encore être le cas
aujourd'hui et ça sera et louis de funès
c'est un génie c'est un génie du comique
parler de charlie chaplin fayat n'y a
pas énormément de comics dont tout le
monde connaît le nom de comics
universelle un génie comique donc déjà
qui appartient au patrimoine universel
du cinéma français c'est un apport
français il y en a d'autres mais celui
là est important
et puis deuxièmement c'est et ça c'est
quelque chose de la cinémathèque c'est
le c'est un lieu du patrimoine
cinématographique français et lui de
funès c'est le patrimoine c'est notre
patrimoine commun c'est notre commun
français voilà donc il a toute sa place
à la cinémathèque et je ne je ne peux
même pas comprendre ce que vous avez lu
c'est d'ailleurs que je ne sais pas qui
est ce type c'est un jeu et je partage
tout à fait l'avis de eugénie bastié sur
le côté c'est moi je suis un auditeur
depuis ma plus tendre enfance du masque
et la plume et alors il ya un jeu c'est
un spectacle aussi le masque et la plume
et on entend des choses au masque et la
plume sur le cinéma me glisse sommet
d'une dune pédanterie d'une d'une forme
mais frelaté de l'édifice je pensais
très célèbre masque et la plume pour
l'obi 1 milliards et des milliards
cinéma est un art et 113 et sur l'iphone
est le togo était enfin à part je disais
ça parce que parce que c'est
insupportable c'est insupportable alors
on n'a pas répété donc vous le fait en
direct
imaginez que je suis frédéric bonnaud le
directeur de la cinémathèque
j'ai regardé point de vue et je vous
appelle tous les quatre ans disent on
vous parlait de 8 funès formidablement
quel film
s'il ne fallait en garder qu'un mettriez
vous pour cette rétrospective
j'ai moi je préférais c'est le cas tous
avec avec jean gabin parce que c'est
extraordinaire le duo s'est un peu connu
et c'est un la siagi mais c'est
extraordinaire
nicolas le coach des gendarmes la série
des gendarmes
c'est vrai que c'est vrai qu'ils
répondent pas aux critères actuels de
parité métis a dû réellement la clcv
droit qu'à un titre de film ce qui
l'attend un sérieux plus grand brésil de
funès la grande vadrouille et le
corniaud adrien maçon de la fin d'un
mois ce serait rapide jacobo si je crois
merci beaucoup et très bon week-end vous
avez deux jours pour regarder tous ces
films merveilleux merci
[Musique]